Hi guys, good evening.
So we will start in two minutes.
If you have any question, you can ask.
Good evening everyone.
Are you guys attending other live classes?
How is it going?
Gen AI interview preparation is going on.
I guess two sessions are going on.
Is it good? Is it benefiting?
It was good but overwhelming.
See if you are a beginner, then it can be overwhelming.
In that case, you can always go and watch the recording.
Because it can happen in a live session, there is a flow.
Teacher is also teaching at a certain pace.
So it can happen that you find it a little difficult.
In that case, you can always go back.
One more thing you always remember that
Because the people who are coming from the industry and teaching you,
They are not teachers, which basically means that
They have not done the teaching work.
So you can't expect anything from them that you expect from a teacher.
So whenever there will be such sessions going forward,
So if someone comes from the industry, he will share his experience with you.
As a student, you will have to put in some extra effort.
Because he will not be able to do the teaching work so well.
Because he has not done it generally.
So you have to be on your toes basically in those sessions.
That's the main idea.
I got some feedback.
I had conveyed to Varun.
So hopefully tomorrow's session will be better than the previous session.
Any other question before we start?
We will start in like two minutes.
Let's wait a little longer.
Some people are still joining.
The other classes are going well.
I guess there are 12-13 sessions in LLM Ops.
Someone is doing a course here.
Is that okay?
Okay.
And what about the other one?
AI Pulse sessions.
Which basically we are doing around current updates.
Ajay is doing the session.
How is that looking?
Okay.
So I guess most of the people here are liking the things.
We will get feedback from other people.
One metric that I have is that the insiders program has a refund rate of 0.
Like literally no one asked for refund.
Which basically means that people are liking it.
This is a direct metric.
At least in EdTech.
It helps us understand whether people are liking things or not.
I just hope that this continues.
One thing that can happen is that I personally feel that there are too many classes.
There are 22-23 classes in a month.
So there can be some fatigue in the coming months.
What can we do?
There is demand from your side.
We are getting classes to fulfill that.
There are so many subjects.
We have to teach so many things that the number of classes is increasing.
So we will talk about that too.
If you feel that the frequency of classes is very overwhelming.
In that case, we can trim that too.
It will only cause a loss that our speed will be reduced.
So again, it's a trade-off.
We will discuss that.
Hardik, we mostly do that.
We always share resources while teaching.
We don't give assignments because personally I feel that...
First of all, you are a college student.
But you are not a school student who needs homework.
You are smart enough to understand that if I have studied something, then it is important to apply it.
So you will take out assignments around your work.
But if you want us to start giving assignments.
So again, I can have a talk with my team.
And then going forward, what we can do is we can also provide you assignments based on the session.
So let's see.
Is there any system design course?
Tarun, not at this point.
But there is a plan.
In the next two months, we will launch the course of system design.
So okay.
I guess there are no more questions.
Let's start the session.
Is it possible to get LLM local deployment and agent development in local machine?
Yeah, it's possible.
The only problem is you need good hardware.
Means 32 GB type.
You will need RAM at least.
To actually have good output.
Is it possible to share what's coming up in the next two, three months for classes?
Doesn't need exact dates.
Just a general idea of what's ahead.
So Niti, as I said, mostly our entire effort is going to be around completing the AI engineer track.
Which we have started and are still continuing.
We will try to complete it by the end of this year.
So whatever is left, like the course of context engineering, the course of AI security, the course of Gen AI system design.
So we are going to work around these courses in the next two, three months.
AI ops has been generic, but if you specifically talk about the AI engineering track, then we are getting you LLM ops.
So the subset of AI ops is being covered here.
Okay, let me share the screen guys and let's start the session.
Thank you Aman.
Krishna, when we will teach Gen AI system design, then the system design of agent AI will automatically come.
Because agent AI systems are also a subset of Gen AI systems.
So both will be covered.
Don't worry about that. Your agents will not be taught to you.
We will teach you agents in this course too.
This current course and LLM ops will also be taught.
So agents will be covered everywhere. Don't worry.
Is my screen visible?
Please give me a thumbs up.
Okay.
So guys, as I promised you in the last class, we have read a lot of theory in this course.
Now going forward, we have to do everything practically.
So all our sessions will be like hands on sessions from today's session.
And the good thing is that since you have read the theory in depth, you have taken a very good overview of the landscape.
So you will be able to appreciate the theory a little more.
So what I will do is first of all quickly I will give you a recap of what we have done so far.
It will hardly take three to four minutes.
Then I will tell you the agenda of today's class and then we will start today's class.
So our course of LLM evals, we established in the first one or two sessions that there are two types of LLM evals.
One is model evals and one is application evals.
And I told you that in the beginning we were more focused on the application.
So we will start today's class.
And I told you that in the beginning we will focus more on application evals.
But before that we will read a little model evals.
Then we started focusing on model evals.
I told you again very early on that there are two types of model evals.
One is benchmarks, with the help of which you can test very specific LLM capabilities.
Knowledge, reasoning, maths.
So to check these things, there are some generic data sets, benchmarks, with the help of which you do these evaluations.
But at the same time, if you want to measure the performance of LLM for your custom application, then you have to run custom model evals for it.
Basically, you run LLMs on your data, on your application and you understand which is the best model for your application.
Let's say you are building a chart board for your company.
Obviously, to build that chart board, you need a brain as in LLM.
But how will you select that LLM?
Simply by looking at the benchmark, you will get top candidates that there are 4-5 good models in the market.
But which one will be the best for your application from those 4-5 models?
The answer to that question is custom model evals.
So we are going to work on exactly this topic in today's session.
Today, with the help of a case study, I will tell you about the best model evals.
How do you get the answer to this question?
Which is the best model for your application?
This is the gist of today's class.
So I have told you the recap and I have also told you the agenda of today's class.
The agenda of today's class is in simple words.
This is the agenda of today's class.
So let me know if you have any doubts so far.
If you don't have any doubts, then just give me a thumbs up and then we will start today's class.
So let's start.
So let's start today's session.
Okay.
So this is a very practical hands on kind of topic.
So here I will not teach you theory.
I will show you practically everything.
And to do that, I felt that there should be a good case study, a good problem statement.
So I explored a lot of problem statements.
I am keeping the best problem statement that I found
So how many of you are cricket lovers?
Like you watch cricket, you follow cricket
How many people are like this?
Since this class is happening in India, I am pretty sure a lot of you will be like
Yes, I follow cricket
So if you follow cricket, then you might have seen this website as well
ESPN Crickinfo
This is like one of the top websites that is used to check live cricket scores
I personally do it too, I have been doing it for years
There will be many more users of this, so this is a proper big website
Now what is there in this website is that when the match is going on
Then people send their questions
They also comment, they do textual commentary
And in between, they also take questions of the users and answer them
So the problem is that since this website works at a big scale
A lot of people follow their feed
So the problem is that sometimes the number of questions they get
Their scale is very high
Like literally in 5 minutes, 500 questions came
And how do you get questions?
Like the match is going on between India and Pakistan
So suddenly someone will ask a question
Tell me how is Virat Kohli's batting average against Pakistan?
Or when India played Pakistan last time, how many wickets did Jaspreet Goomba take?
Right, people ask simple questions
And then they have a team, a commentary team
Some analysts are sitting with them
This is happening live by the way
And the work of these analysts is that the commentary team gives them questions
These analysts have the database of Crick Info
They write a query on the spot
And the commentary team gives the answer to the query
And the commentary team puts it back in the feed
And then tells them
So Crick Info has been doing this for years
But eventually they realized that this is not a very scalable method
Because in matches like India vs Pakistan, the scale is very big
That we can't answer everyone
So what they thought
What if we make a platform
Or a feature on our website
On which any cricket fan can ask any question related to cricket
So they developed this feature
And the name of this feature, if I remember correctly
It is Ask Crick Info
This is the feature
During the match, they give the link of this feature
And what you can do is
You can select from here
What you want to talk about
Let's say you want to talk about IPL
So you can simply go and ask here
Who has scored most number of runs against Bumrah
Let's say you asked like this
Now what this system will do is
Okay
This system will take your English query
And it will go back and convert it into a sequel
So
I am not being insulted, this is being insulted by Crick Info
Simply ask who has scored the most runs
Let's see if we can give the answer to this
Let's see
Okay
I don't know, I checked last time
Something is happening
I don't know
But you understand right
What is happening in this feature
You have made a system or feature
Where you take a text based question
And you give it to an LLM
LLM knows this question
And also knows the schema of your database
That how your database is organized
What columns are there
On the basis of that
This LLM generates a sequel and gives it to you
Then your system takes that sequel
And runs it on the database
Whatever result comes
We show the result back to the screen
So basically we have finished the analyst
That was needed
And we have placed this system there
And now this whole thing is scalable
Because now it can handle any number of queries
Unfortunately, it is not working during the demo
But it is not my fault
You can check after class
So now our case study is
That we have to assume
That we are AI engineers
Working for Crick Info
And we have a feature request
And we have been told that we have to make this system
Now think for yourself
Before making this system
The first question
The biggest question will come
Obviously the biggest question will come
That to make this system
Which LLM should we use
Because LLM is the brain
Main work is doing this
So we have to decide first
Which LLM is the most suitable model
For this application
And as I have said previously
You can't randomly say in your team
Let's use Fable
It is the top model now
You don't talk like this in companies
You have to give good input
Reasoning
Why you will select a model
So there has to be proper evaluation done
Before selecting the model
I hope you are understanding the stakes
So in today's class
We are going to do exactly the same
We are a team of AI engineers
We are working at Crick Info
We have to make a new feature
And before making that feature
First of all we have to decide
Which model we will use
To build this feature
And to take this decision
What we have to do
We have to follow a process
And during that process
We will learn
How can we run custom model evals
On our own data
To select a model
So this is the entire premise
Of this class
Let me know if you have understood this far
Is the problem statement clear
What are we going to discuss going forward
Is this clear
We are going to build
In technical terms
A text to SQL application
But our goal in this class
Is to select
One test model
Which will be the brain of this system
This is the goal of our class today
So let me know
At this point
So let me know at this point
If you have any questions
Then we will start our work
We will start our analysis
Let me know
Let me open the chat
So we assume that
We have rag data pipeline
In place
This is not exactly
Rag
Because
Here we are not
Giving any external
Documents to the model
On the basis of which we have to answer it
We are just providing the schema
Of the database
Which will be the same every time
So we don't need to build a rag chat
This is not a rag chat
This is a text to SQL application
Is it clear
This is not a rag application
So
Let's start the discussion
We will keep it a little interactive
Because this session is planned in the same way
That I will ask your input
At many places
And you tell me
We are working together for this goal
So
Let me tell you the whole flow
The journey of selecting the model
How exactly will it work
We will not start
Directly run custom eval
Do you remember the last session
Where we learnt about LLM leaderboards
Do you remember
We will use LLM leaderboards
In this whole selection process
So let me tell you
How the flow will be
First of all
Always
The first thing that you will do is
That you will understand the problem statement
And then you will write down
Your
Requirements
First of all when an AI engineering team
Is given a task
They write their requirements very clearly
We will do that on stage 1
On stage 2
We will pick those requirements
And we will go to leaderboards
And we will
Shortlist
5 to 10
Candidate models
I told you
What is the work of LLM leaderboards
Filteration, not selection
So how will we know
Which candidate models are there
With the help of these leaderboards
And once we have these 5-10
Candidate models
Then we will run
A custom model
Eval on
All those 5-10
Models and the model
Which will score the best
We will select that model
So is the flow clear
We will do all the work in 3 steps
First we will write down our requirements
We will take those requirements
And go to leaderboards
And
We will select 5-10 candidate models
Which will fulfill our criteria
And then on those 5-10
Models
We will run
Our custom model eval
On our own data
And there we will see
Which is the best model
Of all our candidate models
And we will select that model
To build our application
This is the flow
Is it clear
Ok
Lets go guys
Lets start
First thing is
To gather all the requirements
So we will ask some key questions
I will ask you
And you will answer me
Ok
So quickly type me and tell me
That exactly
For which task
Are we searching for the models
What is the task
At the technical level
I have told you by the way
We are actually building a
Text to SQL application
This is our task
We need a model for this
Next is a very important question
You will ask
Your product manager
Or your engineering manager
That cost
What is ceiling
Cost ceiling means
How much
Can we spend
What do you think
Is a good number
Again this is not
Strictly related to AI engineering
But just wanted to see
How your estimates are
Lets say a website at the scale of
ESPN crick info
Which is seen and used all over the world
We are adding a new feature
So first of all you have to think
That by adding this feature
What is the benefit of crick info
One benefit is
That they used to be asked questions
And they had to write
Queries manually
So they were not able to scale up
So by making this system
They will be able to scale up
But at the same time you have to think
That we
Ask questions
Why do we give them
An answer
Basically we started because
You ask us questions and we will give you an answer
What do you think is the reason
They could have given a commentary
To people
Why did they say that you ask us questions and we will give you an answer
The answer is hidden behind this
That how much money you can spend on this
It is very simple
This is retention play
Any website in the world
What is their north star
That the user
Stayed on the website for the longest time
So what happens is
That these small things
That you ask us questions and we will give you an answer
So we will give you an answer
Any record you ask
This is also a kind of retention play
They want you to stay on the website
And the longer you stay on the website
The more chances you have to see ads
The more ads you see
The more I will earn
So in a way this feature
Is helping me in increasing my revenue
In generating
So what do you think
Could be a good number
That I
Can spend that much money on this feature
If you are a
Business developer
For ESPN Crick Info
You have been given
To build this feature
So what do you think, how much budget will you get
Just randomly asking a question
30 plus lakhs
We are talking about per month budget
What do you think is a good number
How much you want to spend on this new feature
I will see your number
And then I will take out the average
And say the wisdom of the crowd
2 lakhs, 5 lakhs
Let's keep it simple
Because we don't have an answer
So let's keep this number
To be around
Let's say 3 lakhs
This is the cost ceiling
It could be 5 lakhs or 10 lakhs
We will not argue over this
But we asked our business manager
That
How much money is being given to build this feature
So business manager said
You will be below 3 lakhs
Everything is fine
Don't cross 3 lakhs
We have a guideline
Now here is a very important
Thing you have to understand
That how much will be your expense
That you have to take out
As an AI engineer that is your task
So first of all
Let's understand that our
Text to SQL
SQL system
How
will this
Burn money
It is very simple
You are using an LLM
So LLM
Charges you
Per token basis
This is your
Cost, the biggest
Other than this there will be more costs
Deployment etc.
We will not consider the cost of deployment
As the application is already running
So we are integrating this feature
So the deployment cost will not increase
So mainly our cost
Is the cost of LLM
Considering we are using a paid
API, open AI, anthropic type
So here we will do a calculation
Quickly
So what will happen in this whole system
That your application
Your user
Will send you a text
Like he asked
How many runs has Virat Kohli
Scored in the IPL
This is the question
Now what you have to do is
Send this question to LLM
And this LLM will generate a SQL
And that is all LLM has to do
So let's try to
Calculate
How much will be our cost around LLM
So what you do
First of all you don't send this text
To LLM
What you will do first
You will pick up this text
And create a prompt with it
Right
How will that prompt look like
I will show you
So this is the prompt
Which we are sending to LLM
We will read it very carefully
This is our system prompt
This exact thing we are going to send
To LLM
You are a text to SQL generator
Given a database schema
We will provide our database schema
So that you can understand what SQL query you want to write
Given a database schema and a question
Return a single
SQL query that answers it
Using SQLite syntax
Because currently the database
Which we are using in today's class
Is SQLite
You can use anything like oscray or mysql
Return only the SQL query
I don't need any other explanation
From LLM
You simply give me SQL query
Now look here
I have provided the schema here
So apparently
The current schema I have
There are two tables in it
One is matches
By the way, we are operating in IPL domain
Because there are many other things in cricket
International T20
International test matches
Women's and men's matches
So we are narrowing the domain and focusing only on IPL
Imagine that
We are launching this text to SQL system during IPL
So we have a table called matches
In which all the records of a particular IPL match are available
Which match was played between two teams
Which match was played on the ground
Which match was played on the date
All these things like umpire
And one more table
We have deliveries
Where we have
Ball by ball data of every match
So in one T20 match
There are 240 balls
240 balls
40 overs match
So what happened on every ball
That is the data
Who was the batsman on every ball
Who was the bowler
Who was out
All these details are here
So I have sent my schema
And below
The question that the user asked
I have put that here
I have put this question here
And the question is very complex
Which bowler has the best economy rate
Among bowlers who have bowled at least
500 legal balls
It is a very complex question
And I have asked to generate SQL
So this is my prompt
I will send this to LLM
And LLM will give me this output
Okay
I am getting this output by flipping
This is my input
And this is my output
By the way LLM charges us
For every LLM provider
You will get two rates
Whenever you go to any LLM provider
Like if you go to Anthropic
Then every LLM provider
You will get the rate of input tokens
And you will get the rate of output tokens
Obviously output tokens
Are more costly than input tokens
Okay
So first of all we will see
How many tokens we are sending
In every request
So what I will do is
Again, the length will vary
Because all this will be the same
This whole thing
The system prompt written above
And this schema
This is the same
What will vary is the question below
But there won't be much difference
So what I will do is
I will quickly copy this
Entire input prompt
And I will go to
Some website
Which can help me
Calculate how many tokens
Are in my input prompt
So what I will do is
I will simply paste it
And you can see
It is telling us that we can get 352 tokens
Here are the tokens
LLMs will see the input like this
So roughly if we
So if we
Let's
Simplify this
Instead of 350
Let's say 400
So how much is the cost of our inputs
400 tokens
And how much is the cost of the output
For that what we will do is
We will hold this query
And paste it as well
So this is
Around 100
So again
The length of every query
Won't be the same, let's just assume that
On average
We are asking for 100 tokens output
So basically whenever we
Are asking for one request on our LLM
We are sending it 400
Tokens
And
It is giving us 100 tokens
Now here one more important number is very important
You should know that
That on an average
Daily
How many
Questions
Can be asked
How many times
People will open this website during a match
And type the question here
And send it to you, this number is also important
To calculate the cost
Again I need your help, what do you think
A website like
Crickinfo
That operates at the world level
So if we launch this feature
What do you think, in one day
How many questions
Can we get to answer
According to you, again just a rough estimate
I will try to
Do the average
1 to 2 crore is too much
We are just talking about
This particular feature, we are not talking about
The website, we are not talking about the home page
There is a match going on
Inside the home page, this feature is hidden
What do you think
How many people will follow the match
And after following the match, they will go to this feature
And type the question
And you do it, I have never done it honestly
So
Again, some people are saying
Very crazy numbers
Like 1 to 2 crore, not that many people watch cricket
Let me tell you
My cricket
Knowledge, what do I think
I think first of all
It will be spiky
If you plot a graph
Where 1 to 365 days
Are there
And you plot how many questions
If you ask questions, it will be very spiky
Can you tell me
What are the spikes
Spikes are coming according to you
The important matches
In those days, spikes are coming
Like this is a match of Chennai
So more questions can be asked
You understand, right? CSK vs MI
More questions, it will be spiky
But if we want to make an average
Then for a while
We will agree, this is my gut feeling
So I will say
It is possible that on an average
On a daily basis
We will answer 50,000 questions
Now you can argue with this
And it is possible that I am wrong
But for this class we are assuming
That we are going to
Answer 50 questions daily
50 questions daily
So if we
Summarize on numbers
So we have 400
Input tokens
And 100
Output tokens
And
This is a question
And how many questions
Are we going to answer daily
50,000
And then we will multiply it by 30
Why will we multiply it by 30
Someone tell me quickly
It is a simple question
Because we have to
Take out the cost per month
We will multiply it by a magic number
Which is 95
Can anyone tell me what is the magic number
Come on
No man
This is USD to
INR conversion
Because here the rate is in dollars
See
The rate is in dollars
So we need it in rupees
Because we have set our budget to 3 lakhs
So now let us check
That can we afford
Claude fabel 5
Or not
Because our
Newest intern said that use fabel
It is a very nice model
So let us calculate it and tell
See quickly here
What is the input cost of fabel
Input cost is
10 USD
Per million tokens
It is about input
And how much is the output
Output is 50 dollars
Per million tokens
So now we are going to do the exact calculation
That if we use Claude fabel
Then what will be our monthly cost
Okay, see carefully
First we
Will take out the cost per query
What is the cost of answering
One question
So input
Is 10
Divided by 10 lakhs
Multiplied by
How much are our input tokens
400 plus
50 by
10 lakhs
Help me in doing a quick math
Okay, and our
Output token is
So 3 zeros
Are here, 3 zeros are here
So we have 1000 below
And above
4 plus 5
Is it correct
Or am I doing some mistake
4 divided by
1000 plus
5 divided by 1000
So this is 0.009
USD
Per query
Is it correct
This is one query
How many queries are we getting
Per day
So we will multiply this number
With 50,000
So this number will become
Or 3 zeros
Basically
250 dollars
We are spending
250 USD daily
And we have to do this
For 30 days
Now I can do more calculations
By hand
This will be
7500 USD
Did I do something wrong
Oh sorry
Oh my bad
I did wrong
9 into 5 is 45
Or
450 is done
450 USD
Is it correct
And if it is 450 daily
Then how much will it be monthly
450 multiplied by 30
So this would be
Is this the right number
And now we have to multiply this
From 95
To get a number
I think this is around 10-12 lakhs
Right
Multiplied by 95
This is the cost
12.8
Lakhs
Per month
Now you tell me
Can we use Fable
Our budget
Was 3 lakhs
12 lakhs
Is exceeding 4x
So clearly we are understanding
That
This is beyond our standard
We have to go down
Down means somewhere here
Basically we have to go somewhere on 1 4th
Somewhere like
5 on it
It seems right
I think it will just fall in our budget
I hope you are understanding
So first let me know
This discussion
Around cost
Is this discussion clear
Is it clear or
Any question
This is how you do
Calculation, this is how you gather
Requirements
Now here
I am teaching an interesting thing
I could have skipped honestly
Because we will detour a little
But
Notice one thing
This is what you are seeing
5 million
Cash rides
Not 5 million
5 minute cash rides
1 hour cash rides
What is this number
Let's understand this
This is a very interesting thing
So has anyone
Heard this term
There is a term
Which we call
Prompt
Cashing
Does anyone know what this is
Or have you ever heard of it
I guess you have heard of it
Let me tell you what it is
The simple funda of prompt cash is
That
It is possible that the prompt
That you are sending to LLM
In that
A lot of component of the prompt
Is the same
Across multiple queries
Like in this particular case
You can easily see
That this part of the prompt
This part of the prompt
Is going to be
The same for all the
50,000 queries
That you will answer during the entire day
Change is just
This part
But the problem is
The problem is
That you are always
Giving the model
The same repetitive query
Input money
Obviously it's not
Good
So what these model providers say
That we can give you
The facility for cashing
So what will happen
That you take a portion of your prompt
And cache it on our servers
And for that
You don't have to pay money
In subsequent stages
So basically
What does it mean
That suppose you have to
Keep it on the server
For 5 minutes
Your
Text
So for 5 minutes
You will have to pay
$12.50
Remember this is more than
Normal input
This time you are not only getting input
You are also getting cache processing
So these models will charge
$12.50 from you
For the first query
The first question you will answer
The first question
For the first question
You will not have to pay $10
But $12.50 USD
But
Every subsequent
Bar
You will have to
Pay $12.50
For this much
You will have to pay only $1
Instead of $10
So now you can do the calculation
In your head or you can use a copy
You can easily figure out
That your current number
Will decrease
The input one, the output one will still be the same
But the input one will decrease
For the remaining
49,999
Questions
So it will be a significant reduction
Here I would like to clear one more thing
That what does 5 minutes cache
And 1 hour cache write mean
So what happens is
5 minutes
Cache means
That you sent a question
And you
Stored it in the cache
But your next
Question
Came after 7 minutes
So your question
Will be removed from the cache
And for the second
Question
You will have to pay $12.50
To store it in the cache again
But let's say
Your first question came just now
And after 3 minutes
The second question came
So now you have to pay
$1 because
Your question is in the cache
So basically it is a refresh
Cycle
So if you select this one
It will refresh in every 5 minutes
And will be removed from the cache
So since we are ESPN
Crick Info and we are answering
50,000 questions
So for us
5 minutes is a good refresh cycle
Because every 5 minutes
My question will keep coming
It might be that after 2 o'clock
There might be no question
For the next 3 hours
So after that
Our first query will come at 6 o'clock
For that we will pay $1
And will give $12.50 again
And then we will start paying one by one
If you had an application
Which has less users
Like you are expecting
Only 1000 questions in a day
Because your website is not that famous
In that case you use
One hour cache
Writes
In this your refresh cycle is
So you just sent one
Paid $20
And within that one hour
Another question came
So for that it will cost $1
If it comes after an hour
Then you will pay this much again
So I hope you understood all these numbers
And if you have this question in your mind
How does this internal caching work
Then I can't teach you
But I can guide you
This whole thing works on a
Concept called KVCash
KVCashing is a very famous concept
We will also study it in the future
It is related to attention mechanism
That K and V
Vectors which are in the attention mechanism
You can kind of cache them
And because of that
This whole optimization comes in the picture
But whatever it is
I had done these calculations
If you were paying around
12 lakhs to use Fable
Then there is a good chance that you can
Bring it to 6-7 lakhs
With the help of this optimization
You can actually save a lot of money
If there is something in your prompt
Which is always the same
For example
In making rag chart bot
This thing won't work that much
Because in rag chart bot
There is a big part of your prompt
Context
And what is the context
It changes in every query
So prompt caching won't benefit you that much
But here
This prompt caching concept
Can actually help you save a lot of money
I hope this entire discussion is clear
We are doing a very engineering discussion
And
I hope you are not getting bored
So yeah, we are actually
Right now discussing about the requirements
We understood the task
We are making text to SQL
We understood the cost in detail
How to calculate
And plus we have our magic number
That we have to keep it
Within the amount of 10 lakhs
We need this model
So let me know if you have any question
Where do we specify
To use the cache
In the API call obviously
So someone is asking
Without column description
How can LLM understand
What data has in the tables
Few general tables
But for specific to our project
Srinivas again
You have told us the schema
And after that
Describe the schema in your system prompt
It's up to you
Here actually it's very
Descriptive
So I didn't explain it
But let's say my company has a personalized database
Column names
Are very domain specific
Very technical
So what I would do is
I will add one more paragraph
Where I will describe my every column
That control is with me
System prompt will be bigger
I will have to pay more
But again prompt caching can solve that problem
I understand your point
You can provide extra information as well
Few questions are coming
So let's take a small pause
And let's discuss all the questions
Even if we reduce the cost
Of using Fable
Will Haiku be enough for this kind of solution
We will discuss all of them
We are moving forward in the discussion
Let's see which models will be useful
Let's discuss
Sir how does the database get updated
In a live match
Do they do it manually
Or what
A new ball was thrown
Who hit it
All this information is manually
It is available in the database
Scorers are available in this kind of website
Whenever you see a match
It is written there
Who is the commentator and who is the scorer
So the scorer does this manually
So is there any other question
Till here
So Ali is asking
Will reasoning capability of a model
Be involved in text to SQL
So it depends on you
Reasoning
Basically
It is a setting
You can turn on the reasoning capability
So it depends on you
What kind of query you are getting
Maybe you can put another LLM
Whose work will be to understand complexity
And on the basis of complexity
They do routing
That simple question is asked
So send it to such a model
Who is not doing reasoning
And if it is too complex
Send it to the reasoning person
But again the problem with reasoning
Is that latency increases
Because he thinks first and then answers
So yeah
We can do a lot of discussion
Teams do it actually
The questions you are asking
Are asked in the meeting room
But again we have to draw a line
Because this is a 2 hour long session
So we have to do things
But yeah good question
So yeah
Move forward
Move forward guys
Okay
Can we get
Dynamically peak hours and
Low hours query traffic base
Sorry Srinivas
I didn't understand your question
Let's see
Next question is latency
Latency is also a very important
Concentration, you should know
That the application you are making
What kind of latency will work
For example if you are making
A research assistant
Whose work is to go on the internet
And provide information and research
So there latency
Is not a big consideration
But what do you think about this application
Where people will go on this website
And ask questions
During a live match because
They have curiosity
Is it a
Latency is a consideration
Or not
I guess you are able to understand
Latency matters here
What do you think is a good
Number in terms of seconds
That it shouldn't be more than this
If I get the answer in this
Then as a user
I will have no complaints
I think 5 seconds is more
Many people are saying 5 seconds
But I think if it takes 2-3 seconds
It's a good number
In 3 seconds
Our OCD gets triggered
That nothing is happening
Something is wrong, our money will be cut
Something like this happens with us
So let's keep it 2-3 seconds
But yeah this is an application
Where latency matters
Here you can't
Pick up a model like this
Which has a very high latency
Or you can't pick up a reasoning model
Which spends a lot of time on reasoning
And then answers
You have to understand this
So this is also a consideration
The next thing is context
The limit of the context
Shouldn't be a breach
What do you think
For this application
Does context matter
Or not
It's a good question
I am not going to answer it but I am expecting
Correct answers from you
What do you think, does context matter
That how big is the context window
I guess you are able to understand
Here context
Doesn't matter much
Because the context won't be big
The user will come and ask a question
Then the next question
Is a disjoint question
It has no relation with the previous question
We are not having a conversation
There is no multi-turn conversation
It won't be big
So here context is not a big consideration
But if you were making a chart board
Then context matters
If you were making a coding assistant
For this application context does not matter
Because there is no user session
There is no multi-turn conversation
I guess you are understanding my point
If we talk from the deployment point of view
Here basically
We are asking this question
Should we keep open source model
Because it is a privacy issue
Or we can use public APIs
Such as OpenAI and Anthropic
What do you think
Here you can see a consideration
That no, no we have to have our own
On-prem servers
We will put them there
Or we can only keep open source models
No, there is no such consideration
We are not dealing with such data
Where we feel
That it should only be on our servers
So we are open to public APIs
We can easily use
Anthropic, Cloud
I am sorry, Anthropic, OpenAI
All these APIs
Can be easily used
Last question
Correctness
Being correct
Being accurate
How important is it for this application
According to you
Again
It is very simple and logical
It is very important because
Cricket fans will come
Cricket fans are super finicky
About the records
Here I said who has scored the most
Number of runs in IPL
Justpreet Bumrah came by mistake
So a screenshot will come
And it will be posted on Instagram and Twitter
And I will be insulted
For the ESPN Crick Info
So here correctness matters a lot
You cannot be
Incorrect or you cannot hallucinate
So that is a quality
Which you have to check very well
And how will this quality be checked
You will check on leaderboards
That is the coding
Is this model able to do it or not
Because SQL generating is like a coding task
Also with the help of your custom eval
You will figure out
That on your data, on your task
The correctness or accuracy of the model
Is how good
So can we summarize our entire discussion
Till now we are building a
Text to SQL application
The ceiling of cost is given
3 lakh rupees per month
We have to operate below that
Latency should not be greater than 2-3 seconds
Context window doesn't matter much
We can select a model
Which context window is very small
Then also there will be no problem
Deployment is not a preference
In fact we will prefer public APIs more
Because public APIs infrastructure
And reliability, robustness
Is much better
If I use the anthropic API today
And build my application
There is a good chance that API will never be down
If I will set up my own
Then it is possible that I will need a very technical team
And after that it will not be reliable
You understand right
And correctness matters a lot
Because we are dealing with cricket fans
Who are super finicky
If something looks wrong, we will take a photo
And put it in the market
So yeah, these are our core requirements
And we reached this conclusion
On the basis of this discussion
So is it clear
After this discussion
Do you feel you are in a better
Mental state
To actually go out and explore
Leaderboards
You will not do it like this
That you will look at the first model and say
Yes, we will use this
No, now you will feel more literate
Because you have your requirements in your hand
So this is the main goal of this step
Which we discussed in the last class
Okay, let's take some questions quickly
Then we will move ahead
You cannot get everything
If you use a model
Which does a solid reasoning and then gives the answer
Then the answers will come slow
If you use a model
Which gives the answer directly without doing much reasoning
Then the answers will come soon
But you may be disturbed by complex queries
So again it's a trade-off
Which you have to think
How do you handle
I have told you the solution
That you can come and sit in front of an LLM
And with that you can make a decision
The question is whether the query is complex or simple
If it is complex
Then send it to the reasoning model
And the user will also understand
If he is asking a very difficult question
It will take a little more time
We will show it on the UI
Sit tight, churning the numbers
So he will do a little more weight
Because he also knows that we have asked a difficult question
And if he has asked an easy question
Then we will route it to a model
Which is giving the answer quickly
But since the query is simple, it will come correct
You will have to think
So, is there any other question at this point?
Are the requirements clear?
Let's move ahead
So, what we discussed
That we
Will work in three steps
What was the first step?
To gather requirements
We have done that
What is the second step?
To go to the leader board
And
Shortlist 5 to 10
Candidate models
This will be our next task
Okay?
So for this
The first question
That comes up is
Which leader board should we use?
The best would be
If we have
A text to SQL leader board
From the beginning
Then it would be the best
We could directly consult it
To find out who are the top models
Right, and then we would put a custom eval on it
But what do you think?
Are there text to SQL leader boards?
Guys
What do you think?
Are there text to SQL leader boards?
Have you ever seen them?
Actually there are
You simply have to search
Text to SQL leader boards
And you will see
There are two or three
First is the bird SQL
So
It's like a benchmark
For text to SQL
Text to SQL
Tasks
So it exists
But when I
Explored this leader board
I didn't like it
For two reasons
First reason is
It's not updated
Here you will see
There are some old models
And they have considered some fine tuned models
Now Gemini SQL 2
Is not a model
It's a fine tuned version
Which is fine tuned on SQL data
So in that sense
I didn't like it
I can't use their models
So what should I do with this leader board?
Second thing which I rejected
Was
Their way to keep it in full form
Short form
They have named it bird
And they have picked it up like this
Byg
They picked it up
Largely they have
Pick up the R in the middle and made it bird
So I got very angry with this
So I rejected it
There is more
There is a text to SQL leader board
Called spider
My main reason to reject it was
It's not updated, there are no new models
This is also one
But again
They have evaluated all the harnesses
Like
This is Genloop Sentinel Agent V2 Pro
I don't know which model this is
Most likely this is not a model
Some company has made a complete harness
They have made a system
They have ranked it
Then there is another one
Called Live SQL Bench
Now
When I went to Live SQL Bench
There is a leader board
But
It is not updated
Claude Opus 4.6
This is a recent model
5.5
2.6 from KMI
This has brought the next generation of models
And second
Which data they have used
To do this entire benchmarking
I didn't know that
In short I couldn't trust
These text to SQL leader boards
So I saw a fallback
That instead of going specific
To text to SQL leader boards
Let's go to
Coding leader boards
Because SQL generating
Is kind of a coding activity
So
We can extract
From coding leader boards
Information
So in this class what I am going to do is
That I am going to
Use a coding leader board
And coding
Capability
We will treat it like alias
To generate SQL
Basically
How good is the
Capability of SQL generating
Of any model
We will find out from this
That how good is its coding capability
I guess you can understand
We are using coding capability as an alias
So one leader board
Which I liked the most
Is called LLMStats.com
So basically this is a
Third party website
Which brings data from different leader boards
And gives an overall rating
By doing some analysis
So they had a lot of information
So if you go to
Best AI for coding
So they have kind of
Made a leader board
And the good thing is that
It is updated, the most recent models
Fable, 5.6 Sol
All these models
Were rated
Along with some more information
Like the cost
And the speed
And the context
So you can see
Almost every type of coding
Benchmark has been aggregated
And based on that
They have given a rating
So the top coding model
According to this leader board is
GPT 5.6
Then Fable 5, MyTos Preview
5.6
Terra, Kimi K3
And then News 2-3 days ago
It has made a big mess
So it has rated Kimi K3
Claude Opus 4.8
Opus 5 just came 2-3 days ago
So basically all the top
Models are here
Coding models
How many models are there? 146 models
So I thought this seems like
A good leader board which we
Can use
To actually shortlist our top 5-10
Candidates
So now
We have selected
Which leader board
We are going to consult
After that we have this question
How would you shortlist?
These are your
Top
Models
How would you shortlist?
Do you have an answer for this?
Just
Asking
What do you think?
If you were to be
Putted in this mess
That if you select 5-10
Candidate models
What would be your strategy?
Then I will tell you what I have thought
But first I want to hear yours
Anyone?
Just type what do you think? How do you select?
You know the requirements right?
What are the requirements?
You can't pay more than 3 lakhs
Latency should be around 2-3 seconds
Context doesn't matter
See
I will tell you what I did
I selected 5-10 top models
First of all there is one thing
Which is a little confusing
In this leader board
They have not told two different
Pricing
Input and output are not different
If you hover here
They have only told one number
See how that number came
I am hovering on this
Try to read
What is happening?
I want to do anything in this class
But it is failing
Here actually
The definition should come
How they calculated a single price
Here although below you can see
One blended
Can you understand anything from this?
Refresh it
Let's refresh it
Let's hover
Thank you Varun
See here it is written
Blended price per million
Tokens 4 is to 1
Input output ratio
Now can anyone understand
How did this single number come?
You should know how to read all this
That's why I am telling you
Let's take the fable number
Claude fable 5
What was the number?
We saw it here
What was Claude fable 5?
Input was 10
Output was 50
Now what are you doing?
You are blending it in 4 is to 1
Basically what you will do is
You will do 4 into 10
You will do 10
Plus 1 into 50
And divide by
4 plus 1
So this is 40
And this is 50
So 90 by 5
How much? 18
This is the number you can see here
Did you understand how this number comes?
How it comes on single number?
So many leaderboards give you a blended number
So in blended number you have to see
What ratio is used?
4 is to 1, 8 is to 1
Different leaderboards have different ratio
Now what is interesting
Do you remember
The prompt we made
How much was the input to output ratio?
Do you remember?
Input prompt
Which was
How much size was it?
400 tokens
And how much was the output?
I felt so good at this moment
That we don't need to do any other calculation
This blended number
Is exactly tailor made for our situation
Our situation
Our input to output ratio
Of prompt and output tokens
Is exactly 4 is to 1
This means
That I can directly use this number
For my application
It is tailor made
So what I have to do is
I have to do the calculation
In one go
By taking the value of 10
So basically my total
How many tokens are there?
400 plus 100 means 500
Multiplied by
Claude Fabel
So 18 divided by
10 lakhs
This will give me per query charge
I will multiply that
From 50,000
I will multiply that from 30
I will multiply that
From 95
So with this single number
I will get
Total cost per month
So I did exactly that
What I did first
I downloaded all this data
Of 146 models
I downloaded data of 146 models
And then I
Calculated the number of each model
That how much money
Will it cost to run that model
On my application
So like
Claude Fabel got 12 lakhs
And some cheap model got 8 lakhs
So what I did was
Calculated for each model
For 146 models
I took out my per month cost
How did I do that?
Then what I did was
From those 146 models
I directly rejected those models
Which were above 3 lakhs
I guess you are understanding
So some
50-60 models were left
I don't remember exactly
But you get the idea that many models were rejected
Cheap models were rejected
After that now I have
Those models which I can use
And I will have to pay less than 3 lakhs
I will have to pay less money
Now what I did was
I put a simple funda
I first
Normalized their rating
Normalized means
Like I have to
Normalize their rating
Of this model
So what I will do is
50-minimum
Minimum value
In this column
Let's see
So this is a model
GPT 4.1 nano
Which has minus 11.1
So I did 50-minimum
Minimum value
Which is again 50
You learned normalization
In machine learning
So I basically
Normalized this whole rating column
Quickly tell me
What is the benefit of normalizing
So how much
Will the value of this column come in?
Come on guys
0 to 1 right?
So
I got rating of every model
0 to 1
Then I saw this speed column
In which it is being told
That how many characters will be printed in a second
This helps us to understand
The speed of the model
So I normalized this value too
So this also came in?
Then what I did
I put this formula
0.9 multiplied by
Normalized
Rating score
Plus
0.1 multiplied by
Normalized
Latency score
For every model
So I took this model
GPT 5.6
For that I
Took this model
0.9 multiplied by
Normalized rating score
Which will be 1 because
This model has maximum rating
Plus 0.1
Into its rating score
This puts 17 characters per second
Which is very less
Because if there is one model which puts 603
Then assume that its normalized score was 0.2
And I calculated this number
So basically what I am trying to do is
That I am testing every model
First is its speed, second is its latency
I am giving a lot of weightage to the coding capability
I am giving 90% weightage
And I am giving 10% weightage to the latency
Think fast and tell me
Why am I giving such a low weightage to the latency
Don't you think it should have been 50-50
I will tell you why
Here actually
The speed or latency of the character of the model
Matters less because
The output we are getting
Is just a SQL query
Which will hardly have
100 tokens
Which will hardly have 100 tokens
So even if a model is
A little slow
It won't take much time to print a query
You understand what I am saying
If my output was a very big essay
Then latency would have mattered a lot
Why? Because the entire essay
Has to be printed
So if there is a model
Which
Which is
Giving only 3-4 characters per second
Then it will take a lot of time
To print the entire response
But since I have to print just one query
Then even a slow model
Will give me good results
In a decent amount of time
It will print in 1-1.5 seconds
But it is possible that if a model is very slow
Then it will take 2-3-4 seconds
So in this sense
I gave less weightage to correctness
To coding capability
And I gave less weightage to latency
But again this is my personal opinion
You can vary it
You can do 0.9, 0.8, 0.2
You can do 0.75, 0.25
Latency in this application
Does not matter because
You don't have to print too many characters
Even a slow model
Will print a SQL query quickly
So the entire operation
Which I did
From that finally
I got my top 10 models
And I will show you
These are my top 10 models
After doing this entire activity
This model came on top
GPT 5.6 Tera
And its monthly cost was
By the way when I did this exercise
I kept the monthly budget of 5 lakhs
In our discussion we had
Made it 3 lakhs
But when I did this exercise
Before taking the class
My monthly budget was 5 lakhs
So that is why
Some of the models
Will be around 4 lakhs
This is its throughput
And this is its overall score
This score which we calculated
This one
0.9 into this
So let me
Tell you again
What was my entire filtration strategy
I went to the leaderboard
First of all I
On the basis of cost
Removed all the models
Which will give me
More than 5 lakhs in monthly expenses
So some models were left
Now in some models
I had to create a ranking
On the basis of ranking
I had to create two things
One its coding capability
And the other its latency
Or throughput, how many characters per second it is giving
And I had to combine
These two into one number
So I first normalized
These two in the same range
0 to 1, simple
We have learnt that in machine learning
And then I gave them a weightage
I gave coding 0.9
Latency 0.1, behind that
The reason behind that was that latency
Doesn't matter much in this particular application
Because you have to print a very small
SQL query, how much time will it take
To print 100 characters
So that's why
This was the weightage
And according to this weightage
I assigned a number to each model
And sorted them
And by sorting
I got these top 10 models
So these then are the
Best models that I can use in my budget
I can try out
Now among these
This model is Muse Spark 1.1
We can't use this
Because it is only used in the US
It is a model of the Shook and Meta
It can only be used in the US
Apart from this, yes, we have other options
But
Now we have to select the best
Of the other models
Now here
You will see some interesting things
Like the ones that are paid
Like GPT or Claude
They are actually costly models
But there are certain open source models
Such as
Minimax M3
Which is very cheap
And it is not even very behind
If you see
It is not very behind
Like if GPT 5.6
Terra 0.9
Latency plus coding capability
So Minimax
In a very low cost, in a fraction of a cost
Is giving you 0.76
Not far behind
And now this test is still pending
On which model works on your application
So this was very interesting
So now we have GDM, GLM
All of these are getting cheaper
And GPT and others are getting a little more expensive
Sonnet is coming in the middle
So now what we will do
We will pick up the rest of the models
And we will use that
Basically
We will put it
In our custom model eval
Which will test on our task
That how the capability of these models is
And again because this is a live class
So we cannot test all the models
So I have thought
That I will test 5 models
And show you
First one is
GPT
This one, basically I will color it green
We will do this
Because it is a top candidate
It is a little expensive but it is a top candidate
It is open AI so we will try this
I personally want to do Kimi K3
Because I have heard a lot of praises
In the last one week
We will definitely do GROK because
You never know
Elon Musk
What he would have done
We will do Claude because it is the only one
Which comes here from the
Anthropic family
After that GPT 5.6 could have done Luna
But we are doing Terra so we are not doing Luna
Because there is a good chance that
Terra will give a better performance on Luna
Because both are coming from the same company
After that
In GLM, Quen
And Minimax
We are going to do this because all three are Chinese models
So we will do this
Why? Because
In very less money
It can bring us results
And Gemini 3.6 Flash
Could have done it but left it
So this is the first one
This is the second one
This is the third one
This is the
Fourth one
Which is the fifth one
This is the fifth one, Kimi K3
We will test the last models
You guys
Can test dozens of them
You won't be able to do this, it is not available
But you can do the rest of the nine
I will tell you exactly how to do it
You don't have to do anything, we will make a list
Just add the model name
That will also be evaluated
But since it is a live class, I will show you five
And in those five
We will see which model really comes out
So here
We have cleared stage 2
Stage 1 was
To gather requirements
Stage 2 was
To shortlist 5 to 10 models
From the leaderboard based on your requirements
And stage 3 is
To run custom eval
Which is the last
Part of this session
So is it clear? Till now discussion
Is it making sense?
Or no?
To be honest
If you have read so many theories
Then you are able to enjoy
These practical discussions
You are feeling
That yes, I have more stakes
I understand all the things
I am able to think a little more
Questions are coming in my mind
If I don't read all those theories
And take a class directly
Then you will feel
What is being said, I don't understand
That is the main difference
I was saying that theory has to be prepared
And I have read this over the years
And it is very unsexy
I know, many people
Will leave in the first, second, third session
But those who will stay
In the 7th, 8th session
They start deriving a lot
So I really hope this class
Is interesting
And you are deriving value from it
So
Any questions at this point?
Question from the audience
Actually
We are shortlisting
So this question doesn't come
This question will come when
We will run custom eval
And we will get the result
There will be a question
That does GPT 5.6
Justify our price
Or we
Use the M3
Because it is very close
And again it varies
Application to application
It is a very sensitive application
Like a medical application
Where you cannot be wrong
Then you will pay extra price
To be more correct
But let's say it is a consumer grade application
Where there is not much of a stake
So to save cost
You will select a little lower model
It depends on the situation
On the application that you are building
Any other question?
I will wait for 30 seconds
Then we
Will move to the last part of the session
So far everything
Is it looking logical?
I don't think I have
Used my own will
And you think sir
You did not do the right thing
Are you able to resonate
With my reasoning?
Or somewhere you feel that no sir
You are running your own
It doesn't look like that
How to estimate for multi-turn conversations
I mean the input and output tokens
It will keep on connecting
The previous one
It is a little difficult
But your history will keep on connecting
How to do that calculation
You will have to sit and think a little
It is not that straightforward
Like in this situation
It will be a little estimate based
Let's move ahead
And then
So guys now comes
The last and most crucial part
I have 5 candidate models
And we have to select
One of these 5
And now what we will do
We will run it
On our data set
On our task
So I will tell you the whole flow
What is the whole flow
That first of all
You need a
Data set
Which will already be with Crickinfo
So I also
Brought that data
From where?
From Kaggle
On Kaggle it is IPL's complete data set
From 2008 to 2024
So we will use this database
We will use this data set
So we have the data set
Next thing is
That we need
A golden
Data set
Basically we need
A data set in which
I don't know
30 to 50
Questions
Like one question
That
How many
IPL's
From 2018 to 2022
Were killed?
This is your first question
In your golden data set
And then
We will write
Its SQL query
Who will write this SQL query?
Our data analyst
And he will
Write this query
And run it
On this database
And validate it
That yes, this SQL query
Answers this question correctly
Then we will
Add more questions like this
That Jaspreet
Gumbra from 2012
To 2016
Which matches
Did he play on which ground?
We added this question here
Our data analyst will come
For this question
Will write a SQL query
And that SQL query
Will run on the database
And validate that yes, the query
Which I have added here
I have done it correctly
And like this
You will make a list of 50 questions
Which we will call our golden data set
Now while making this golden data set
You have to be super careful
That you keep this data set
Very representative
To the distribution of
The user questions
So what will you do?
Out of 50, it can be 10 easy questions
Then you
Keep 20 medium questions
And 20 hard questions
Because it is possible
That you get to see this kind of distribution
Then you will try to create
A lot of variety in this
You will want 5 questions on the joints
5 questions on the sub queries
On the window functions
So you will try to keep
All the possibilities
On this data
So this is how you create
Your golden data set
You create it manually most of the times
Or if you are getting it done from an LLM
Then you make sure
That the whole thing is correct
But yeah, at this point
You will have two things
First you will have a data set
Which is obviously with Crick Info
And second your data analyst team
Will bat and create a golden data set
Okay?
Once the golden data set is created
Now the evaluation work
Starts from here
What will you do?
During the evaluation
You will enter
Your golden data set
You will pick up every question
You will pick up question 1
And send it
To an LLM
So you have 5 candidate LMs
You will test one LLM at a time
Then the other one, then the third one
And then you will test the fifth one
So let's say we are testing the first one
5.6 Tera
So what we did
We picked up question 1
And sent it to 5.6 Tera
What did Tera do?
It generated
A SQL
Now what will we do?
We will pick up this SQL
And run it
In our database
And along with that
What we will do is
The first question in our golden database
The SQL query
The golden SQL query
We will run it in the database
There are two queries
One from the data set
And one from LLM
We will run both of them
Now think and tell us
What will be the criteria?
How would we check that the generated query
Is correct?
Can we
Match the string?
Tell us quickly
Can we directly
Compare this generated query
Character by character
With this query
If character by character is same
Then the correct query is generated
But is it a good strategy?
Is it a good strategy?
No, because for a single result
Multiple queries can be written
Achieving a single result
Through multiple queries
Is possible
So it is possible that the query
That your data analyst has written
And to solve that problem
The query that your LLM has generated
Both are different
At least
Textually
But how can you
Check that you run both
On the database
And you will get
A result set from both
Basically a table
This will be table 1
This will be table 2
And what you do
You compare these two tables
That are they both
Same?
If they are both same
Then it means that
Your generated query is correct
This is how you check
That generated query
Is correct or not
Same thing you will do for question 2
Question 2, question 3, question 5
Question 50
And against every
Question you will get to know
That is it correct
Or wrong
And once you
Will do for 50 questions
Then you simply get accuracy
So you get to know that
Accuracy of 5.6 tera is
95%
Then you will do
The same thing for whom?
For second model
Then for third model, then for fourth and fifth model
And after doing this whole operation
You will have accuracy of 5 models
On your data
And that is the right representation
Of how your model is performing
On your task
So is this entire process clear?
How to run custom eval?
Step by step let me revise
First you need a database
Second you need a golden
Data set in which there will be a question
And the correct query will be there
Then what you will do is
Load each model and one by one
Send questions of golden data set
For each question the LLM will generate a query
So what you will do is
That generated query and the query of golden data set
You will run both on the database
Both will get the results and you will compare
Both the results by value
To see if both are the same table or not
If both are the same table
Then the query is generated correctly
The query is not the same
You will do this for 50 questions
And you will get the average and accuracy
And that will be the accuracy for your model
And you will repeat this for all the models
By the end of this process you will have your answer
Which model is the best?
So is this process clear?
This is what we are going to do
Let me know if you have any questions
I will wait for 30 seconds
Can we make a golden database
Of golden data set
Of 100 questions also? Is there a limit?
No, no, there is not a limit
There are two problems
The first problem is that
Golden data set is generally made by humans
So here
You will have to pay to make a golden data set
It takes time and effort
It takes money
The second problem is
As you increase the size of your data set
You think
How many LLM calls are you going to make?
You have 5 models
And you
Are giving 50 LLM calls to each model
That is like
250 calls
If you do 500 questions instead of 50
Then that is 2500 calls
So you are giving money in your evaluation
So there will be a budget
So you have to be careful
For that also
As I had taught you
50 to 500 is okay
And new questions are added
When you deploy
The new question where your model is failing
You add it in your golden data set
That is how you decide
Since the classroom setting is there
So today I have brought 20 questions
20 questions
Very difficult questions
How we decide
Between using frameworks like
DeepEval and creating golden manually
So I will not answer this question today
Because this is not a topic
We have not discussed about DeepEval
So there is no point in discussing this
When we will do further
Obviously frameworks give you more benefits
They give you more ease to do all this
So when you read DeepEval
I will teach you
So guys
This setup is understood
Now I will show you step by step
I have mostly written the code
But I will show you in the end
So that you also get a little kick
So see we will work step by step
I have written the steps
I will show you
You will enjoy it, you don't have to do much
Just see, observe
If you have a question then ask
So what are the steps
So what I did
I didn't think much
I downloaded data from Kaggle
And I put it in the data folder
Can you see
These are the two
Deliveries.csv
And matches.csv
These are the two files I put here
Also to keep things a little more simple
During the evaluation
I took one more decision
In the data set we had
Data from 2008 to 2024
I trimmed it
And I have kept data from 2020 to 2024
Data from 2020 to 2024
Simplified it a little during the evaluation
Because otherwise
It will take more time
So data set is clear
We will use IPL
Data from 2020 to 2024
After that in step 2
Right now our data is in CSV file
We have to load that data
Where
In a database
And which database we will use
SQLite
So here I have a file
The name of the file is
db.py
If you go and study this file
Then here is a simple code
It looks like there are many lines
But what we are simply doing
We are reading these two files
And
We are taking the data from these 4 years
And storing it in a database
That's it
So you will notice
When I run this file
The name of this file
is
db.py
So here a database will be created
ESPN
Crickinfo has this data set
We are making it on the go
See
This is our data set
Okay
So here is
Data from 2021 to 2024
There are two tables, deliveries and matches
Now we have loaded the data in the database
So now we can run SQL queries on it
So I guess this setup step
Is also clear
Now the next is a very important step
We
Our database
We have to extract its schema
Basically we have to tell how many tables are there
And which columns are there in each table
And what type are those columns
Someone can quickly tell me why we are doing this
Why do we need the schema
Quickly type and tell me
Why do we need schema
Where will we use schema
Guys
In system prompt
Right, I showed you at the beginning
Did I show it here
I showed it here
See
This thing
I have to provide this
In system prompt
I have to tell which tables
Which columns are there in each column
I have to send this information to LLM every time
So I have to extract it first
So what we have to do in the next step
In a file
We have to extract the schema
So I have written a code for this
Again, it is a simple code
You can go and read it if you want
By saying schema extractor
Now the simple foundation of this code is
That it will go
Study your database
And
Generate schema from it and store it in a file
Again
We are not going into the code specifics
You can just go and
Check the code
So I am just running this
Python 3
Schema
Extractor
.py
See here a new file will be made
See
Schema.sql is there
And see in this
This is schema
There are two tables
And all the columns of those tables
And their type we have kept in one place
We will load this
Ok, so is this step clear
We have done this too
Let's tick in front of what we are going to do
Now comes the most important step
Step number 4 where we have to
Create a golden dataset
Ideally, you should
Do this manually
But I
Obviously, I got this done from an LLM
I gave it these instructions
To make a set of difficult questions
Although this is not right
You should also keep easy questions
But since I wanted to show you
Which model is performing well and which one is not
So I made a set of difficult questions
Of 20 questions
Ok
And obviously I had to run it
To see if it is working properly
In my database
So I made a file for that too
And the name of that file is
Golden Dataset Generator
If you see here
Here every dictionary is
One
Question
Like this question
What is the average number of runs
Scored per match
Give a single number
Ok
This is the question and this is the query
Now think of it as
This data is written by the analyst
I have labeled it as a hard query
Ok
And how many queries did I make?
And the code below
What does it do?
When you run this file
All these queries will be run on our database
And will tell
Whether the query was run properly or not
So if any query is bad
Then error will come, then we will know that
There is a problem with golden dataset
So what I will do is
I will quickly
Do this
I will simply write
Python 3
Golden
Dataset
Generator
Dot py
I have run it
See what it is doing behind the scene
It is running all the queries
And it is telling that 20 out of 20
Queries passed
Here we are not checking that the answer is correct
Here we are checking that
There is no SQL error
Queries at least are properly formed
So we checked this
So we have 20 queries
Now what we have to do is
Put it in the CSV file
That will be our golden dataset
So for that also I have a file
Make golden dataset
Its simple work is
That this golden dataset generator will go in the file
And the 20 queries here
Will extract them and make a CSV file
So basically I have to go
And I have to just write
Python 3
Make
Golden
Dataset
See here a new file has come
Goldenheart.csv
If you go here
You will see that this is our
Exactly the same 20 questions
First question is what is the average number of runs
Per match
If you go ahead of that then here is the golden query
Apart from this we have added
A little more information
Like
What is this 1
1 is the number of rows
How many rows are we expecting
So here we are telling whether the query is order sensitive
Means
Limit
Order by descending, order by ascending
Is being required in that query
So like in this particular query
It is false, which means order by clause is not used
Why is this clause used
We will discuss it later
But whatever it is, in this step what we did
That we
Not only created our golden dataset
We also validated it
We also ran all the queries
We checked that everything is running properly
And lastly we also stored it
In csv format
So
6 steps out of 12
Is there any problem at this point
In understanding the whole flow
Let me revise it once
We brought the dataset
We put it in the database
Extracted the schema
Made the golden dataset
What did we do in making the golden dataset
First we made the golden dataset from LLM
We checked that everything is running properly
So we put it in the csv file
We have done it till here
Is it clear till now?
Is it clear?
Guys
Is there any question till now?
Okay
Now what we will do
We will not directly
Test the code for 5 models
We will do it like this
First of all
We will run the whole flow once
What is the whole flow?
Golden dataset
From the golden dataset
We will extract one question
Let's say
Q1
And we will send it
To an LLM
And we will see
If we are getting a SQL query
Or not
We will test it
This will help us understand
If our setup is working properly or not
By the way
We have to test 5 models
One of them is openAI
One is Anthropic
One is GROK
And maybe 2 Chinese models
So
All these models have different APIs
OpenAI
Anthropic
So what should we do?
Should we write a different code for all?
Or do we have any other solution?
Is there any place where we will get 5 models in one place?
Guys
Do you know a platform or a service
Where we will get all the models in one place?
Perfect
Saurabh was right
I guess you must have heard about this platform
Open router
Great platform
Through this
You
Can use any model
You can use its API
For example
You need Kimi K3
It is available
You need Terra
You need Sonnet
It is available
Great platform
And the best part is
Its direct integration is also with line chain
So whatever you have learned in line chain
Chat, OpenAI
You can talk to any model through OpenRouter
So for this particular demo
We are going to use
OpenRouter
The good thing is that you get some free credits
So even if you can't test all
You can test 1-2 models
You can test it with full accuracy
I have done it myself today
But to run all of them
We had to spend some money
Around 5 dollars, 500 rupees
So that's why we are going to use
OpenRouter for this particular demo
So here we have
A file called
FirstTest
And the simple work of this file
Is
Here
We will have to change one
From
.env import
load.env
And
We will have to do
Load.env
I will not use
The API key
And
Do I need to give the API key somewhere else?
Ok, basically what we are doing
We are selecting one model
Which is
GPT-4
Is the model of OpenAI, this is not our candidate model
We are using it to just check
If our flow is working properly or not
What it will do is, it will pick up a question
And will send it
To the model
And through chat open router
We will just find out
If we are getting a correct SQL or not
That's it, we just want to test
The whole flow
So what we will do is
We will simply write
Python 3
First
Test.by
See
This is the question we asked
And we got this answer
By flipping it
A SQL query
Nothing else is visible except that
Which basically means that our system prompt
The whole flow of the code
Will work properly when we use it
So this was just a test, even if we didn't do it
It would have worked
So what we just did
Checked the flow
Is it clear?
I guess there is no problem
Now comes
Step number 8
Pick candidate models
So we made a file for this too
Here you will see a file
The name of the file is
Model open router slug
We have made a list in this
In that list
We have added 5 tuples
In every tuple
We have named the model
And its slug
On open router
We have picked that
Because it is necessary during the hit of the API
So you will see
If I go to open router
And I do sonnet 5 here
So this thing you can see
This is the exact
Thing I have written here
I searched for every model
If I had to do 10 instead of 5
I would have searched for model 10
Their official name is on open router
I would have put it here
So this is kind of my
Model database
So this is step number 8
I hope this one is also clear
Now comes
Very important step
Step number 9
Build the evaluator
Basically we have to
Create a rule
Create an algorithm
With which we
Can compare our results
What we have said
On one side we will run
Generated SQL query on database
On the other side
We will run the query written by
Data analyst
By running both we will get
Two results sets
We have to compare both
If they are same or not
If they are same then model has generated the right query
This was our discussion
So for this whole thing you have to write a logic
The same logic
You will get to see in this file
Evaluator.py
Here
There is a lot of code
But in nutshell what this code does
When two data frames are given
One is
Golden data frame
When did he get this data frame
When we ran the golden query on database
And when did he get the generated
Data frame
When we ran the generated query on database
We compare both
In this function
And I have written a lot of logic
Of comparison
Like I will tell you quickly what is the logic
Like if you have
This is table 1
And this is table 2
You have to compare both
That are they same or not
So first of all you will test
That are their numbers of rows
Same or not
Think and tell me
If the number of rows of two tables are different
Then can they be same tables
In a sequel result set
What do you think
Guys
If you get two tables
You searched
Who is the top 5 batsmen
You can see 5 rows in one
And 3 rows in the other
So obviously the 3 row query was wrong
So first you will check on the row
After that
You will check
What will you do
First of all the values in both the tables
You will kind of
Normalize them
Normalize means not the normalize
Which I told you earlier
Not the min max
Normalize means
Like
There is decimal value at one place
2.0 and integer value at one place
So at one place 2.0 is there
And at the same place 2 is there
So you will treat them the same
Because you will not want
That if you treat them separately
Then it will be wrong query
So you will do this
Or you have
2.9999
And at the same place 2.9999
So you know that they are same
So you will
Normalize this too
So all these things we have done
In the file
This file has exactly the same code
That we are checking
That are the rows same or not
If they are not same then it is over
If the rows are same
Then we are normalizing all the values
We are doing multiple things
After that what we are doing
That in both the tables
The
Values that are there
We are organizing them row by row
This is table 1
And
We are doing the same for table 2
And then what we are doing
We are comparing
These two
If the values are same then table is same
And if
Order matters
Like by the way
We are sorting first
Sorry I got confused here
Let me tell you again
First you checked if both the rows are same or not
They are same
Then what you did
You normalize all the values in the table
After that
You set the values of both the tables
Like this
In the list
In the form of tuple
After that what you will do
You will sort these values
Okay
These values will be sorted
And you will sort the one below
The other table too
And when sorting will be done in both the tables
Then you will match
That the results of both the tables are exactly same or not
We are doing this because sometimes
It can be reordered
One value in a table
Row is on number 1
And the same value in the other is on row number 2
Depending on the variation of the query
That's why we are sorting and comparing
But if order matters
Which we will know
From our golden query
From our golden data set
Here we are telling
That whether order matters or not
For that query
If order matters
That means if there is order by clause
Then we will not do this sorting
And will compare without sorting
By comparing without sorting
We matched that means both of them have set the right order by clause
Otherwise it's false
So we will test this too
And there are 2-3 more checks
It's already 10 o'clock
So I am not going into details
Just understand that
In this file
This evaluator.py file
We have put a lot of effort in it
Just to make sure
That when two tables are given to you
To compare
You can compare them properly
And tell the correct result
And you can see that in evaluator.py
This part is a bit rushed
But again this code will be given to you
Just put it on the line by line
You will understand
Just summarize the logic
So going back
We have
Evaluation logic
With which we can tell whether the generated query
Is giving the correct results or not
Now the last thing
Is to orchestrate the logic
And this is the last file
Which I want to show you
Which is main.py
And what is the whole work in main.py
See it's written here
Load the model
There are 5 models
Load the models
Run the golden data set on every model
After that run the generated SQL
On the database
And run the golden query on the database
Evaluate with the help of
Evaluate.py
And log the scores at one place
It depends on the files
Schema.sql
Because with that we are making our system prompt
Golden data set
Obviously it won't work without it
Model open router slug
From here we are getting the information
And from evaluator.py
We are getting the information
That whether our result is correct or not
This is the flow written here
You will see simply
What we are doing is loading schema
Loading golden data set
Connecting it to the database
Then run the loop for every model
And what we are doing in the loop
We are just calling the model
Bringing the SQL
Executing the SQL
And then calling the function
Evaluate
Which is written in this file
Calling this function
This function is telling us
Whether the result is matched or not
Or
We are logging everything else
This is the main task
So now without
Any delay
What we will do is
We will simply do the
Final task
Which is we will run the main file
Main.py
And we will hit enter
And the task will start
And task
Okay
There is one problem
Our file name is
Golden.hard
And in this code
We have assumed the file name
So I will rename it
I will make it
Golden data set
Which is expecting our code
Let's run it one more time
And
Now see guys
Our evaluation has started
First of all we are working with 5.6
Terra
The first question was done correctly
Okay match means
The query generated
Result of that and
Result of the golden data set query
Failed in the second one
So there is a mismatch
The third one matched
And now this will be for 20 questions
GPT 5.6 Terra
And this will happen
With every model and eventually
We will have our result
Let's wait, we can wait in this
So at this point
If you have any questions you can ask
I will wait
So so far
GPT 5.6 Terra is going fine
7 questions
I have evaluated 8
Only one error has been done
Which was the second question
Varun yes
Obviously you will use
These AI tools
You can also do a very simple version of this
Coding with your hands is not a big deal
The whole project
It is very simple
Because if you understand logically
You can see some extra code
And comments because I have generated the code myself
But it is not difficult
It is very easy to understand
Never
At the level you are at
Don't take the pressure to understand the code line by line
What is the whole file doing
What is the function doing
If you understand that then you are in control
Think like this
See guys question number 10 failed
Failed on 11 because these are brutal questions
I have labeled it brutal
Because these are really difficult questions
So far 3 have failed
Rest all are correct
GPT 5.6 Terra
Meanwhile you can ask questions
Because I can't do anything
The screen will come slowly
And it will be for 5 models
So you will have to wait for another 10 minutes
Can we do a proper
E2E end to end text
To sequel project which involves
Complex joins reasoning etc
The goal of this course
Is not to build projects
It is to evaluate projects
So we can't go to make projects
In this course
Mostly I will make something
And then test it
In LLM eval we cannot build projects
That is not the point of this course
So far it is going well
There are 4 errors
In 18 questions
Failed
80% came
GPT 5.6
Any separate class on this
May be not part of this eval course
That we can do
Where is the scope
You are doing 6 classes in a week
You have to see the scope
Rest there is nothing difficult
You can do it
I am studying basics
Kimi K3 has come
If you don't know
This new model has been recently launched
Moonshot AI
And it is a model of 2.7 trillion
Parameters
And people are saying that
It is very close to Fable 5
1 third of the cost
And it has created a lot of rift
In US share markets
Because such a powerful
Frontier model has come from China
While being open weights
Not exactly open source but open weights
So let's see how K3 does
I have a lot of expectations from this model
Let's see
Does GPT 5.6 beat it or not
See question number 6
There is a sequel error
What does this mean
There is an error in that
So this is not right or wrong
This is a syntax error
This is coming here
So
Not good
Meanwhile you can ask questions
We can have a discussion around
Whatever we discussed
Is normalization
Generally better than
Just one second guys
Is normalization generally
Better than keeping everything in a single
Table while normalization is usually
Preferred wouldn't it increase the error rate
For sequel generation since queries would
Require multiple joins as complexity of
Sequel queries generation
Which normalization
Are you talking about
The one which was applied on LLM leaderboard
Or the one which was applied on data
This is performing very badly
In K3
In 3 questions there is a sequel error
The same famous saying
China's stuff
Oh you are talking about database normalization
You are talking about
Is normalization generally better than
Keeping everything in a single table while
Normalization is usually preferred wouldn't it increase
The error rate for sequel generation since
Queries would require multiple joins
For analysis
De-normalized tables are preferred
Obviously
So if this entire activity
Is around analysis then you will use
De-normalized tables only
For transactional databases you do
Normalization
So yeah ESPN Crick Info team
I am pretty sure they have already
Normalized or de-normalized the data
Obviously
Normalization is
Good for transactional databases
Or de-normalization is
Good for analytical databases
There are some terms too
I don't remember exactly
There are some terms
OLTP
OLEP
There are some terms
Online Transaction Processing
Online Analytical Processing
Also you know what I am noticing
That K3 is
Very slow
You are observing this
Maybe because it is a big model
Plus it is a reasoning model
I haven't touched anything in reasoning settings
So there is a good chance that
It is taking a lot of time in reasoning
It is a slow model
Latency issues can occur in this model
Plus also it is not performing very well
So I don't think it will be able to do this
In our task
This is a very good example
To understand if you see
If a very sluggish model comes on the leaderboard
It does not
Guarantee that it will do that much
Good on your task. This is a very good example
KVK3 is being spread in the news
But when we put it on our task
See what is happening
It is slow too
And it is not performing great
So this is a very good lesson
Which you have practically seen
K3 reviews are not good on Reddit
So we can see the reason
People must have tested their own
They must have used semi-bals
See it is very bad
I think it is getting 50% accuracy
Two more questions
Let's see
We could have done latency
How much time it took in the whole activity
We could have done that too
But I have not written that code
I will do that code tomorrow
Six are SQL errors
Apart from that
I can see two mismatch
Most likely it is around 50% accuracy
That's bad
For a frontier model of this scale
2.7 trillion parameters
Is not a joke
55%
GROK came
I was getting bored
I could have brought this from home
I could have brought it from home
But I thought I would get a kick
If it was in front of me
But now it feels like
It is taking longer
GROK is
Clearly faster than
K3
It is getting faster
And there are no errors yet
GROK cracked the second question
Did both of them do that wrong?
Yes
Question number two was in our golden dataset
In that, GPT and
Chemiketri both failed
But GROK did it
In fact, there is no error yet
I always find GROK underrated
Also, you can never underestimate Elon Musk
In brutal question also
The brutal question
Question number nine
That also went wrong
Will it not get any error?
It's here, first one
Commentators first
Right
You have seen that live
Guys, there are two more models after this
But I am hoping
That MINMAX
MINIMAX
That will be a little faster
And what was the other one?
I don't remember which one
SONNET
SONNET will also
Be faster than these
Because
I don't know how many parameters
But it should be below OPUS
It has to be faster
Is GROK 4.5 the most recent one?
Or is there any generation above it?
I haven't followed
Which one is the most recent
Does anyone know?
Is it the most recent one?
Okay
Yes, Tarun
And this is not done by project manager
AI engineers only do this
Because
It's a very technical job
Then you will report it to project manager
And then
He can take the final decision
But a lot of input will go from your side
This is a very bad photo
Only two mistakes have happened so far
So it's like
90% accuracy
It's fast too
Right?
It's also fast
How much was GROK's expense?
Let me quickly check
How much was GROK costing?
Just one second
GROK was
2.5 lakh
It's almost half of Tera
It's very less than Kimi K3
It's still a clear winner
It's at 90%
Look at SONNET
It's so fast
It's already done 7 questions
Let's see what happens on brutal questions
SONNET
It's a good model
And it's SONNET 5 by the way
It's near previous generation of Popus
It's also lost 2 questions
One more mistake
It's done in brutal for sure
But it's very fast
I think
It's faster than all three models
I'll give you one more
It's faster still now
It's clearly visible
85%
Nice
How much is SONNET's expense?
SONNET is
at
GROK is still cheaper
Oh, here comes our
Dark Horse
It's already done 2nd question
What's the 2nd question?
We'll have to see
3 models are still wrong
10th and 11th
But that was
brutal question
It was very difficult to set
That's it guys
This is the last one
Once this is done, we'll conclude
I know it took more time
But I think
I've done a lot of coverage
I've discussed a lot
It seems like
we are colleagues and working for a company
and we are concluding a project
I feel like that
GROK is faster than
MINIMAX
I think it can be at 3rd
MINIMAX is gone
China's product
It's coming in Chinese models
SQL error
Aman is right
Not bad as the latency is very good for SONNET
We can push for extra 25k
These will be the discussions
MINIMAX is gone
3 in a row
It's coming in Chinese models
SQL error
SQL error is coming in American models
SQL error is not coming
They are giving the right syntax
Their syntax is disappearing
Is it being written in Mandarin?
I am writing my own SQL
I have banned everything
So I will make my own
I know
Tell me what do you think
Who is the winner?
Who will you select?
This is a small dataset
It should be a bigger dataset
In 20 questions
1 question is carrying 5%
The dataset should be bigger
But I think in bigger datasets
GROK will beat
You can have multiple runs on the same dataset
Because there is no connection
The next API call
is independent
You will get more statistical evidence
That we have run this evaluation 5 times
Still
Top score is GROK
On an average 5 runs
You can do that too
But you will have confidence
That even after 5 runs
We are getting the same result
Last 2 questions
I think 5-6 questions are wrong
65%
Here is your final result
The poorest was
Kini K3
90 and 85
So it is basically between
GROK and Sonnet
Right
Because Terra is very costly
Terra is very costly
So why will we
spend this much
So question is between
GROK and Sonnet
Because
Cost is close
Their index was also equal
From the speed point of view
Throughput is saying that GROK is faster
But in our experience
CROD was faster
With Sonnet
There is a little bit of anthropic reliability
In its API
So in that sense
You can give Sonnet a little bit of priority
You decide guys
We have 2 finalists
GROK 4.5
And CROD Sonnet 5
These are our candidate models
You decide what to do
I will incline towards Sonnet
In this sense
Because the company seems more reliable
To me
So their API and everything will be more reliable
So GROK
GROK has a little bit of Elon's personality
So I don't feel it is reliable
So maybe I will go towards
Sonnet
Because it is a more stable model
But yeah
This can be your decision
We can also have a voting
This also happens in companies
When you can't take a decision, you do voting
But yeah
That's your session guys
This is what I wanted to teach
Now you tell me if you have any questions
This was our today's session
This is what we discussed in the beginning
We have achieved our
Goal
How was it?
Did you enjoy?
Yeah
Ok
Just a little
One thing was maybe a little rushed
That was the code explanation
I tried to explain it
In two hours
You will get the code tomorrow
Try to do it with yourself
You try it in some other app
Test2Sequel is one thing
It can be something else
you will understand once you do it
I am at the last minute, you can ask any other question
Thank you guys, Happy Guru Purnima to you guys also
We can do the same activity in system design in future
It would be real valuable, we can prepare something before class to discuss in a better way
or else their case studies will be in system design
What will be our next course after evals? AI security
Sorry Upinder, I haven't made github repo yet
I am working on my local machine, you will get it tomorrow
unfortunately, sorry, I haven't made it yet
I have to go home now
So, okay, see you in the next class
See you in the next class
This part of model evals is completed
I will tell you this quickly
This part, we have completed this part
Model eval part, okay, benchmarks are done
Custom eval run is also done
Now going forward we will focus on application evals
Model selection is done, now how to do application, we will do that
So, now I will close the session
See you in the next session, bye, good night